[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe
happy hey babe to you
happy hey babe to you
happy hey babe happy hey babe
happy hey to you
somebody turns
37 today
today
today
is the greatest yeah
you remember
green fish smashing pumps it pump
smashing blumpkins i never could ever
tell apart smashing lumpkins
green day
or foo fighters or savage garden
they're all the same you put savage
guard in there with them
does a savage garden have like one hit
or maybe sound garden sound garden is
what you mean that's what it is savage
garden had like one or two hits on like
the friends
soundtrack
what does savage garden sing
i knew i loved you before i met you
yes i know i loved it what is that i
don't even know how i knew i loved you
before i met you i don't know it i could
be wrong i watch it not be that old a
scale on a scale of one to ten how could
you think you're doing a job of
conveying the song to me i right now i'm
at i
sing it one more time and then i'll
i knew i loved you before i met you
i knew i dreamed you into life
you're a savage garden stan yes i'm a
christie savage gardener let's hear it
cvs csv
there you go
you've never heard this song oh this is
horrible sorry savage cotton
this is bad i mean it's not for me i'll
say this they're doing it on the new
york city subway oh i know this now
oh
oh wow i now that i hear this i know
what you were singing
oh this is bad huh yeah this is like but
this is like what was this night or the
early 2000s but like it was 2009 but no
way it was it had to be even before that
whoa she's in the video what's her name
kirsten dunst kirsten dunst is that was
that kirsten kirk kirsten dunst from
spiderman or was that the girl from home
not home alone or is that was that um
homeland is that is that the girl from
not stepping up is she from homeland
no no that's claire danes it's from
homeland that's kirsten dunst spiderman
from spiderman but what does she do now
she's from step off no step off bring it
on
bring it on because who's the one julia
styles is the one from step up i
confused the three of them julia styles
if you can tell upon julia styles
kirsten dunst and claire danes claire
julia style kirsten dunst and claire
danes
are my
sound garden savage guarded smasher
blumkin
green day yes well i mean claire danes i
like claire danes as a blonde you know
they all they look very similar the same
woman it's like it's like the um
the uh other guys you were talking about
uh from independence day bill pullman
bill pacquiao bill pullman bill pence
they don't look the same but people get
their names but i think all three of
them are alive can you just flip through
them again
okay okay ready we'll do flash cards
don't look at the names just look at the
faces okay ready pimp you just pick
anyone you want right away you say who
it is right away okay
kirsten dunst
uh um
uh claire danes claire danes
i don't know who i who is kristin oh
that is correct no no that's that's
kirsten dunst then that's jordan styles
oh then who's julius oh that's really
style from bring it on yes or step it up
oh step it up where is it bring it down
what what movie is julia styles famous
for stephanie it was her and who did she
co-star was it tyrese
hey babes big big news chris and i are
coming to stand up in baltimore maryland
together you guys been waiting for this
i think yes and now it's happening it's
october 1st uh tickets are available at
lyricbaltimore.com
they are
pre-sale right now
and the promo code is babe and only you
know this oh so you get it right now you
get in there right now and you get your
tickets right now because tomorrow
they're on sale to the general public
yes sir we need the babes in there we
want to give it to you first also more
babe news i will be at the wilbur
theater november 21st because the shows
that laugh boston november 18th to the
20th are all sold out so we added the
wilbur theater that's a sunday november
21st the pre-sale is happening right now
christy comedy.com for tickets that
promo code pre-sale code is chaos okay
chaos because some crits of chaos well
today is a big day this thursday because
also on sale as of 10 a.m this morning
no pre-sale i will be at the moon tower
comedy festival in the paramount theater
headlining a set uh that is september
24th in austin texas tickets at
salvocanocomedy.com they just went on
sale today so you can get really good
seats right now that's the moon tower
comedy festival in austin september 24th
uh i'm also playing denver at the
at the what at the bellco theater in
denver on saturday september 25th i'll
be with david spade and frank caliendo
it's a charity event and you can get
tickets at savile counter comedy.com
clarice he pushed me at a party i told
you that you did was it julia stiles and
and tyrese or was it julia styles and
omar epps no omar oh julius what's up
don't go up no channing tatum was it
save the last dance
that's the movie i'm talking about sir
you got served or something uh channing
tatum and you got served
that's nick somebody got served
down at south park
like oh man the boys the guys the kids
come back all heard of them like oh and
just like the boys got served down by
the parking lot by the walmart they got
served they got into a dance battle and
came back off
i will tell you those three women are
are
are hard to discern i think they've had
like a they have a similar look a
similar frame right maybe a similar i
don't know like a similar gate right you
know you ever hear that the term gate of
course you should be physical therapists
of course you should gate g-a-i-t not
g-a-t correct gate i can actually
usually tell
what problem you have going on based off
your gait and i know this is a little
you know you just have to when you're
going through like you know
it's it's very very very intense to
study like a doctorate level stuff med
school is even crazier it's very very
very intense but we would mimic just to
like break it up people's gait all the
time as physical therapy
so what you did was you mocked them
physically we would [ __ ] like if so and
so had this disorder or that thing
happened to them we would be like yes
you're gay and we would do like you make
them need other therapy from the
physical yes and no not in front of them
behind their backs can you imagine
you're in front of them you're like you
go like this
you dummy but we would we would and but
we would do it sometimes like we would
do it like unannounced it got to the
point where like somebody would just
walk into class somebody would just walk
into class and then you know just be
doing it so like stroke left hemisphere
you know
oh you could do a walk that would
indicate a medical issue 100
because for example you know if you had
a certain type of stroke you might get
something called drop foot where like
that this this and that part of the
brain control this and that nerve and
your foot would just drop or you could
have another type of you know hip injury
or things like that and we would do it
and come in you know with uh you know
all different types of stuff um
so it was pretty dude thinking back to
physical therapy school and i mean how
hard it was like how like just in like
lit literally i was in physical therapy
school from 2007 to 2010 the yankees won
the world series in 2009 i'm a die-hard
yankees fan i
cannot even tell you a second of what
happened it's like it's like the exam
whatever happened in life before between
2007 2010 i have no frame of reference
for i don't remember any of it
it's crazy do you still feel that that
was i mean there's nothing you could do
about it but i just mean do you still
feel
satisfied happy
what you're doing now versus all that
intense studying for years
yeah you're happy to leave it behind are
you happy that you have the base
knowledge to move with you through life
or do you feel like you just would have
known you wanted to be a comic sooner
cut all that out do you think you
couldn't be here without being there
first
tell the people what they want to know
so i would first of all great question
multiple choice i would say b i would go
with b and d i would say both answers
are correct b what you said was take
that knowledge and move through life d i
wouldn't be able to be here unless i did
that both of those things are true the
amount i've always felt i always felt
from you know some of our peers
especially coming out doing comedy open
mics and obviously you know how
difficult it is to make it in comedy and
to just get paid to do it there's you
know
hot now hundreds of thousands of people
doing comedy and it's just very
difficult to break through but i never
felt
nervous about
like literally just taking the biggest
swing possible in entertainment because
i was like i i have a doctor
i have a physical therapy license to
fall back on right that cannot be taken
away from me although it technically was
taken away from me because of my license
relapse but then the panduini came came
out and then governor cuomo r.i.p
reinstated the license i don't know now
though he's the one who reinstated it
but he's now no longer the govs so i
don't know if i'm still technically
reinstated it has to be i can't imagine
that the new government is going to take
a full and and ruin your reinstatement
that she might come the new governor may
say listen anybody who got reinstated
any physical therapist you have to
understand that was not my call so
you're out i don't think she's going to
do that when is that bigger issue when
is there going to be a polit a disgraced
female they don't exist god bless
disgrace
you know
when when's going to be like this woman
you know she grabbed my hog or whatever
like you know what i don't know not like
like that i don't know if listen if
you're a guy who has been a victim from
a woman in power and you're gonna come
forth don't call it your hog don't call
it your hog yeah yeah hog is is rough
but
security video shows mayor bodyguard
during early morning cemetery visits
what uh a female mayor is caught
cheating on her husband in the cemetery
[Laughter]
she was like there's no one going to see
us here yeah i mean she's different i
mean that's her personal business but
yeah she went into that summertime i was
like listen things can't be any more
dead than the relationship i have my
husband so i might as well just
do it here
tennesseemilk.com by the way was just a
website that went up so now please go to
tennesseemilk.com what is that just give
them a shout out
covered security video that shows how
the two managed to find some time inside
nashville's most famous historic
cemetery
when i
oh boy had a
it happened
an extramarital affair
ever since the mayor's admission
and so in public in like outdoors on the
clock
on the clock outdoors on someone's grave
so there's literally is somebody's tax
dollars had to pay for her to have sex
on their grandmother's tombstone that's
what the tax dollars went to wow
i mean if this was 20 years ago and she
was a rapper
she would be she the patron saints
that's badass in a way that depends on
what handler you're picking it up from
it's either disgraceful or badass badass
you choose now did she lose her job for
this
she was a woman well yeah she's she
would lose it for screwing
you know for a workout she would lose it
for having sex during work hours and
disgracing is it also defiling public
property if she's yeah i mean if you're
having sex on a on a tombstone you think
it was planned do you think that just
lust took over in the moment when they
were making the rounds at the at the
cemetery you think they went there
because the cemetery would provide good
cover i think two things are true i
think most likely how it happened is
with an innocent joke i think probably
what happened is they were at a funeral
of a co-worker or someone they needed to
be at
and she's standing there security guard
they're lowering down the casket they're
lowering down the casket and she says
something to the effect of that's nice
wood on that casket and then he says if
you want to see nice wood here it is and
then one thing leads to another and then
he says to her you know she says to him
you know it's so funny you say that
she's like it's crazy being in a
cemetery because nothing can be more
dead than the relationship i have my
husband and then he says well you know i
can help you with that i'm a security
guard you're safe with me and then they
i think they probably wanted to back
into the mayor limo or whatever it may
be i don't know what city they're in
might have been the mayor yeah the mayor
trailblazer security video
shows wow security video showed it so
there's there's pictures of them in the
act
october
the tuesday before thanksgiving it
arrived at 7 29 a.m and the monday damn
holiday weekend they were back at 7 21.
yeah but what's the problem why can't
they drive to the cemeteries
but how do they know you're cheating if
you're just driving to the cemetery
maybe you'd like to take the scenic
route recently it's january 8th
every single morning at 7 30 in the
morning like clockwork they both wanted
it every morning at 7 30. they're like i
could not do mornings i was going to say
i can't 7 30.
wake up get in the car go to the
cemetery
i mean 7 30 they're at the cemetery
they're already shouted and they're in
their slacks
yeah so they're getting up at five
o'clock just for daily appointments that
have sex amongst the dead how quickly do
they come out because they went in at 7
36 what time they come out that says
funny if the news person throws shade
like here they are again going in at 7
31 leaving at 7 36. so what were they
doing there the mayor spoke to him
to be a peaceful place to start her day
he added sometimes she would go for a
call catch up on emails or blow her
security guard
hey i'd like to report myself
she's like i'm out of here laying on a
tombstone yeah
yeah those are the she probably knocked
over the tombstone how dare she go
and and and and and and and and and and
have sex there and then simultaneously
call in vandalism i mean
these politicians stones
the politicians stink
but how again
just because the jeep the car went into
the city they're in in it together so
it's just him and her
yeah they're alone and where is he
tennessee is this new
well we're happy to we're happy to bump
it back into the new stream i'd love to
get them both as guests on the podcast
i'd like to get her but when is there
gonna be a mayor that like like is like
runs
her finger down your back and says yeah
what's going on whatever cuomo that i
just saw a couple
listen it has to it has to uh
it has to have happened
it was her i know but that's one
we have millions of fallen
it has to it has to have happened
a lot but i just think yeah i mean
listen
go ahead no say like a female politician
you know doing that to a guy
you know i just don't know how many of
them are reported so you think it might
happen
it's just received differently and it
doesn't it doesn't come out in the
laundry the same way no i think it just
hits the group text
that's what i think
i think that's that's where it gets
reported it's in the group chat should
women be running everything
there's a debate right because they
don't start wars either they don't
participate in war no and and you know
what they're very um i mean they
participate in war but like
i mean historically they're not driving
war no and they're very they they
usually they're they're a lot better
they're a lot better at knowing what a
scam is they're a lot better at staying
true to their word and allegedly you
know in power position powers they have
way stronger backbones and don't waver
from the original choice i was talking
to a guy yesterday
who used to work in ad sales and he was
just saying like the intensity of ad
sales and what they would say to them
like day one every new person they would
say do not they were calling it pitch
the [ __ ] they said don't pitch the
[ __ ] meaning in ad sales obviously you
know whatever that's derogatory whatever
they would say don't pitch the [ __ ]
meaning if a woman picks up the phone
asked to talk to her husband asked to
talk to her son ask to talk to her uncle
ask talk to her brother do not pitch her
someone would be when they cold call you
mean yes do not pitch her anything
because you will not number one not only
will she say no she will identify us as
a scam because that's what we are so
they would say so and that's what the ad
guy told me he said they knew that they
would you know it was like they would do
things like you know pitch fake
yearbooks so it was just some boiler
room ad scam which happens all over the
world right so they would say but the
women
you never ever ever even tell a woman
that what you're doing or even try to do
it because she'll know it'd be great if
that boiler room scam had like an hr
yeah and they were like you can't say
that yeah yeah yeah scam them yes you
know call them up sell fake yearbooks
but you can't say don't pitch the [ __ ]
no not do not not that this is not that
kind of work listen
by the way if a woman if a woman picks
up you hang up the phone immediately she
will identify the scam but don't say
pitch to that is that how you um then is
that the secret to getting rid of uh
robo like call calls like unwanted
solicitations
just have to have your wife or or
girlfriend pick up the phone or not even
just like hello i was going to say
every time the phone was hi
this is a woman that's wild that that
could be such a stereotype that it was
an industry-wide yes known thing to not
pitch to a woman because they would but
they were just
and the guy would just be like i'll have
10 yearbooks yeah i know i mean could
you imagine somebody called you and said
i mean have you ever entertained an
unsolicited call to your house for even
longer than 10 seconds
i'm just like click no the only time i
actually did the only time i actually
did i don't remember how old it was i
had to be in my early 20s but some
solicitor called me and i again i don't
remember the product so it's not like it
worked but i stayed on they i picked up
the phone and i said hello you know
whatever and then the guy i said hello
and the guy was like hi uh can i speak
to a mr anthony de stefano who's my dad
yeah and i said well he's not he doesn't
live here anymore he goes this is the
police we need to speak to him and i
said oh my god what has he done i swear
to god i said oh my god like what what's
going on what he's done he goes i'm just
kidding and then he says
i swear to god completely illegal
completely illegally insanely illegal he
goes i'm just kidding and then he said
you know i'd like to talk to you about
you know your electric bill
or whatever it is
but i remember staying on and telling my
mom about that and her being like oh my
god
but i was a kid
that's funny i'm having one of those
days where it's like it's just one of
those days
it's just one of them days
that's a girl just goes through when i'm
angry inside
don't want to take it out on you
it's
just them days don't take it personal
i just want to be all alone but you
think i'll treat you wrong it's one of
them day just one of them days a girl
goes through
when i'm angry and tired
don't want to take it out on you
it's just what it is
i don't know what you just sang you
don't know that
unless you're not singing it right again
you knew what song i was singing right i
don't know the song
what how did you look it up listen
by a key lyric
you know this song i know monica
you've never heard this song i need let
me let me get to the
i love the whole new jack swing era and
this r b era
so baby don't you lean just one of them
yeah of course yeah
that a girl goes through when i'm angry
inside
i didn't rock this song a lot i don't
know it like at the back of my hand you
don't know every word to it but but now
that she's singing i know peripherally
the song um were you doing it justice
i'd say you were doing your best version
i would say if you looked at my spotify
playlist right now it's of a 16 year old
black girl from 1997. yeah that is my
music brandy monica swv sister with
voices i know i love leo
i get so
[Music]
babe how about this you know what i'm
doing tomorrow and i'll report i'll
report on it
next week's hey babe going to the mets
game with steve cohen the owner of the
mets and his wife oh it's all happening
because of the hey babe show when we
talked about the disaster gig i did for
steve cohen the multi-billionaire owner
of the mets who the show billions was
based off of has invited me and my
girlfriend to the game we are sitting
there tomorrow with them
at the game as a belated birthday gift
and i'm gonna let you know what happens
with also tommy mottola and his new wife
or who's a a big time latina singing
sensation they because she's puerto
rican i think or whatever it's like jazz
you're going into the met game with
steve cohen the owner of the match tommy
mottola the owner of music yes that's
what i'm doing
you you might be able to get in both of
the areas you might you might be able to
recommend the new chart top or the tommy
mottola and you might be able to get in
steve cohen's ear about some back office
stuff and maybe some maybe some player
rotations and things like that i'm going
to i'm going to pitch them ideas all day
i'm going to ask if you want to come on
hey baby you you should
you should but you should pitch them
some people that aren't great that are
busts in order to help the yankee
organization yes
yes because because here's the thing i'm
going in as an undercover yankees fan i
told you in the beginning of the show
i'm a huge yeah i don't even know it
they know i'm like
but i'm going in undercover meds because
here's my thing and i'm a die-hard
sports fan so i know some of the sports
fans might be like you can't do what i'm
about to say but i don't care because as
governor cuomo said we're new york
strong so new york so new york i believe
that's still a good quote you can still
that's a good quote yeah
still like if you just isolate the quote
we are new york strong we are on you
know who said it never mind never mind
um um
so and new york tough
so so so
i will say that i believe being from new
york and rooting for a new york sports
team
supersedes everything so i am not saying
i am an equivalent to yankees and mets
fans that's for people who don't know
anything about sports they just say and
they're idiots shout out mayor bill de
blasio you can't just flip up and do
that but you do and that's why the
people in new york for the most part
don't like it because it's that so so so
so
i will say though i am a die-hard
yankees fan but i do not hate the mets
and certainly when the yankees are out
of the playoffs if the eggs are out of
the playoffs and the mets are still in
it i would 100 begin to root for the
mets i will never under any
circumstances ever root for the boston
red sox or anybody in the al
but the red sox i will not that does not
mean i hate the city of boston as a
matter of fact i'll be there in november
shows are sold out so i
saw christy comedy.com so i so i do not
hate the people of boston
furthermore if you are from boston and
tell me that you are a yankees fan i do
not trust you and i will not trust you
right same as if you are from new york
and you tell me you're a red sox fan i
do not trust you and i will not trust
you because you have you cannot be from
those two respective cities and like the
other team it it just tells me as
character of you as a person
we don't mesh because
as pimp and his croonies would say
you're sucks
bring back croonies too by the way
crooney's is an old word cronies
crooneys
cronies
you're croonies crooney's like a crooner
as like a
uh frank sinatra type a crooner he's
going to pimp hangs out with
cronies are like your
you know your henchman he hangs out with
a group yeah they're called the falsetto
fives yeah yeah no no you don't yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it's his crew is the false set of five
oh so you really so i have it wrong you
guys call it the crooneys yes because
you can sing falsetto they're all people
on my leg right now i'm yes oh my god i
believe it's almost one of those things
right i can't believe the level holy cow
i can't i can't believe that we've been
friends for as long as we've been and
you fell for that one no that's one that
like my mom would have fell forward i
didn't want to be so sure of myself i
corrected you but then when you you gave
me the the reason that he has friends
that sing falsetto so they call
themselves the croonies instead of the
cronies i thought that i was real but
he had a very genuine look on his face
as he nodded who's your favorite sports
team
i don't like sports can't trust him
yeah you shouldn't
you have zero allegiance across any
sport whatsoever to anyone at any time
ever
not even anything nothing mma is cool
everything else i don't really i could
take it or leave you don't care it's
just church for guys it is
it is by the way cronies is often
derogatory according to wikipedia fyi or
the google dictionary sorry but it's
awesome companion he went gambling with
his cronies you know what i do see the
derogatory i thought crony was a
derogatory term but they they don't
spell they're not defining it as such
right friend best friend companion
familiar intimate
associate comrade colleague workmate
none of these seem derogatory but yeah a
lot of people are like oh it's one of
his cronies one of his cronies yeah like
his hangers on his slackies yeah
with some don't give me that crony
baloney yeah you know i've never had
bologna either that's the one thing i
also thought of i know we've talked
about foods i've never yeah but i've
never had baloney because my my class
i'm missing too much in eighth grade but
my they tried to convince me and tell me
i don't know if the people at home email
heybaypodcast gmail.com tell me if if
you've you know this ever happened to
you but my friends used to convince me
that if you put ketchup
on bologna on white bread it tastes just
like a hot dog i've seen many people do
it i've never done it myself we could
try it at the first ever live baby pod
on august 24th seoul joel's well it's
two days later we actually just did it
two days ago okay guys and we added two
more shows we did one yesterday too
sold out shows at soul joel's you missed
everything um sal you were telling me
the other day that you're looking for a
ready lineup of binge worthy podcast
podcast plus free streaming music and i
didn't have any answers for you but now
i do what's that amazon music okay
that's what i that's what i think you
should go i've been looking for i've
been unhappy with my other streaming
services you've been talking to me about
that i have he was on the phone with the
other night for three hours talking to
me about there's no binge-worthy podcast
platforms and i cannot find free
streaming music anywhere
but amazon music isn't just for
listening to podcast i listen to all the
podcasts on there listen hey babe yeah i
listen to taste buds i listen to chrissy
chaos yeah but i also listen to my jazz
you do you listen to your jazz and you
know what you know what is great about
amazon music that you can play it on
your tablet your phone in the car on the
go at home in the gym etc there's no
credit card or subscription required for
amazon music you pay them in cash
that is the one thing you have to put
cash in an envelope and you have to meet
someone that works at amazon and make
the exchange and make the exchange no of
course we're kidding you just don't have
to subscribe but you know which is great
because that's how they get you is they
say hey it's free and then all of a
sudden you you know you forget about it
for two months and you you've been
paying the whole true no credit card or
subscription required if you've never
tried amazon music what are you guys
waiting for you're gonna love it as much
as we do start listening for free today
head over to amazon you've heard of
amazon right dot com slash hey babe
that's amazon.com hey babe to stream
thousands of music stations and over 10
million podcast episodes if you have the
time for free amazon.com
america's number one meal kit
hello fresh fresh fall's busy yeah is
getting very busy but hello fresh
recipes save time and you'd otherwise
spend meal planning shopping and
chopping so you can get back to what
matters your family your friends
my girlfriend and my kids have told me
they said you know what you've been so
present you've been so you know your
time has been so valuable to us lately
so what's changing life i said now i'm
cooking with hello fresh i have more
time on my hands i'm i'm more present
we're in the kitchen i'm making a lot of
different types of spanish spices well
how about this your family's growing
hello fresh's family menu is a big win
the back to school season with easy
delicious recipes for drama-free dennis
who wants drama in their dinners you
know what i've met a few people in my
life that want drama in their dinners
and i said you know what no more drama
mary j blige i'm not dealing with that
anymore the only thing that i will say
about hellofresh for their friendsgiving
stuff is they don't they they don't have
pumpkin cinnamon rolls and that's just
the only thing that i'm upset about no i
think they do
stop that's a news they have pumpkin
cinnamon that's a new seasonal recipes
when have i ever lied to you why would
you even i feel terrible right now you
think i'm lying yeah they have pumpkin
cinnamon rolls and friends give friends
giving ready sides as well as fresh high
quality ingredients that travel from the
farm right to your front door in less
than a week sal i know that this is hey
babe and we like to keep it clean but
get the
yeah yeah yeah i i i don't know i can't
tell if you really want me to leave
i don't i do want you to leave i do want
you to leave and while that door and
i want you to listen to something okay
when that door is hitting you on the ass
yeah on the way out because the way you
just [ __ ] with me yeah i want you to
listen to one thing and one thing only
okay go to hellofresh.com
hey babe 14 and use the code hey babe 14
for up to 14 free males including free
shipping now get out of here that's
absolutely wild
[Music]
all right have you guys ever heard this
word i've never oppo
oppo
oppo
a colleague or friend an old oppo of
mine oppo
it sounds like it's saying uh oh
why is the why is there a thick accent
on that person
i mean i
like i guess they're just that that's
just a person so it's oppo in in
our
apo
i never heard the word oppo in my entire
life
oh informal british
oh informal british that's why it's
british apo but even the informal
british sounds pretty awesome to me it
sounds very formal yes you if you could
change your you like your accent do you
like your american new york accent
are you like that's a coveted accent
i'll take it or do you buy into any of
the little bit of blowback we get
for stereotypical like we sound like
goons i think i sound completely
different in my head than what i
actually sound like when i'm talking i'm
like oh i sound like a tough new yorker
and then when i listen to myself back do
you stand up or watch the podcast i
legitimately sound like like a gay queen
right from like the 1960s you've got a
bit of both going on and i think it's i
think it's endearing i think i have the
same yeah i got a mouthful of marbles
sometimes i don't pronounce and i get
lazy and then sometimes i also sound
like
just of just a just a very uh
i don't even know what
yeah i just i feel the same way like
sometimes i'm like yeah man what do you
think do you think
sound gay sometimes
do you guys sound good oh i know we do i
know i don't know i'm not i'm not saying
that's part of my stick i'm like not
just sound but like definitely fool
around and like
i don't think i can really judge i sound
worse
you don't sound gay no i can't even a
lot of the fans have written that i
sound like tina from bob's burgers
how you feeling by the way do you feel
better good yeah yeah you have a cold
you had a cold
over it i'm over it yeah i feel like
everyone's getting a little something
hopefully a little a little something
some i got to be all my opals are going
down oh it's open crazy tell me if
you've ever had a daylight here are the
top five here here's the top five for
the world's sexiest accents british okay
french italian spanish irish i disagree
with yeah irish i i would i would say no
on the irish
actually it's it's cool yeah i think
it's really freaking cool and i love
like listening to it but i don't know if
it's sexy
sec i like it and i love ireland and
scotland these are great places in
england
because i love the weather people could
speak and i would have no idea what
they're saying no scotland people you
know yeah like they sound like all shrek
like when we go over there too
they tell me they love our accent
and they they're like oh it's just the
new york accent is such a sexy accent
everyone tells me that old men
that's what they're saying but you hear
would you take a french italian accent i
would probably take a french or italian
accent
i would take i would take it's exotic
here you know what i would take i would
take the spanish from spain accent just
to just to go ahead with the list but
not feel bad about it because my name is
chris
my name is chris my my nombre is chris
bistephanol yeah that's what i would
like to do just because i very sexy
because sometimes when i have the lisp
yeah you know it's
sal
ibiza
ibisa sal i would like someone with
shrimp
uh and sal my name's sal you know if you
spoke that way
you probably
it probably wouldn't
you your job would be affected big time
oh you think you'd have the career you
had if you spoke that way do you think
you'd have to get a job where it's not
so
dependent on you
great yeah
can you fix a lisp
but with spanish from spain it's not the
lisp it's just like like they don't it's
it's just a dialect it's just a dialect
so it's not
they can
do with a list but i do a lot of people
list shout out people i love you
we see you shout out joe lisp who's joe
there's joe list meetings over tuesday's
stories his brother joe lisp
he had different last names by a letter
yeah yeah
scotland i i like can wait i want to see
how long i can keep us a scottish
scotland
or is does that or i what's this this is
scotland and then ireland but i don't
know if i i can't tell the difference
between i know ireland off the top but i
i can tell when someone's from scotland
or ireland scotland scotland scotland
scotland yards now you
would have you i
can you say something irish i have to
like listen to becky lynch or conor
mcgregor or something all right let me
let me try from ireland so let me try
from island turd from i'm from cav i'm
um oh hello dear i'm from calvin county
ireland ireland i'm from calvin county
ireland oh would you now would you like
a tea all righty oh yeah would you like
your tea would you like a teeth but from
scotland i would say i'm from edinburgh
scotland would you like a tea you cr
would you yeah would you like a tea
bollocks
your cronies
hello i'm from london would you like a
cup of tea love yeah you do them good
you should be an accent you should do
accents in your and then this is from
spain hello would you like would you
like some would you like some
hello would you like mint leaves
oh no
hola hola buena
hola bono stuff would you like mint
leaves in your tea
[Laughter]
i don't know what accent that was no
yeah i you know it's annoying i had a
friend go uh like years ago it was like
15 plus years ago they went backpacking
for like the summer and came back and
like brought home some of the accents
from the places
and i was like no it's just not real
yeah don't like i get like
maybe
maybe
picking up a slang word or two yeah and
being like i called it that for months
just to kind of like you know yeah but
even that you're not going back and
being like
oh can i have a [ __ ] you know
whatever but like you've been in the uk
for extended periods of time i've been
there for the most maybe 12 13 days the
thing that you do pick up some of the
things like when i get home the first
thing when i get back to new york i may
say hey do you want to do you want to
eat internet or you want to get carrie
out they call it carryout okay you want
to go get carryout and you would you you
might adapt to the carriage adapter
take out i'll say oh you want to get
carry out that's very minimal also
you're like you're like i gotta go to
the loo that's why what's up or if i say
hey you know was there what are the
people queuing up for our show
okay might say that because you just
hear it constantly but you're not
dropping the accent on me no no no i'm
not i'm not going to go full
the capacity for accents
accent change among adults has been well
documented by linguistic
linguistic and olive oil linguistic and
clam sauce researchers over both the
short term temporarily in the context of
a single conversation and the long term
slowly evolving based on exposure to
other accents over a period of years
so there's a capacity for change in
dialect over the course of a single
conversation yes
that's insane
i feel like i take on people's style i
feel like i can i'm i i'm a chameleon
with you know um
like i will talk like the person
who i'm talking to who i've known for a
while like i may not have the same
diction i may not have the same dialect
with you as i would with
sergio chico and my friend sergio right
because we just have different
mannerisms different things that make us
laugh and trigger us right then i do and
don't do sure sure i get that you know
yeah
so i but you know i don't know i mean i
mean
dude i've been having it's my birthday
and i've been having a day it was one
you ever have one of these days where
you at
literally as soon as you wake up it's
like level 10 you feel like you're
chicken without a head like literally
has not i mean as soon as i got out of
bed it was it was level 10. yeah it was
go you're late go get the kids doctor's
appointments you're late late late late
late moving moving moving no gym you
feel fat you're eating a bagel with
crumb cake disgusting get here do the
podcast and then boom boom boom boom
boom do you ever have like what does
that feel like to you like what do you
have that yeah
cause you're so busy i don't have
children you know but like so that has
to be
level 10
because i'm sure all bets are off with
the kids because i feel overwhelmed with
just my regular stuff right you throw in
a few kids in there yeah i don't know i
don't really know how that works it it's
it's one of those things because you
know seem well put together
it's one of those you know i was talking
about this uh i was did andrew schultz's
uh flagrant two podcasts uh a couple of
weeks when him and i were talking about
this
where i he was saying to me he's like
you look like you're
you said you look like a well-adjusted
like you look like he's like and he was
like but i know how bad you suffer from
anxiety and stuff and i was like yeah
dude like like i'm
literally like on the inside right now
dying
dying on the inside like have so much
[ __ ] to do and so much and just kind of
like always thinking like come on come
on come on i gotta do this you gotta do
that like get home the kids absolutely
hate the way i feel in my skin right now
i feel so fat and out of shape and
ashamed with myself that i've just been
eating and like a pig and not going to
the gym and i i just feel physically and
mentally disgusting but
i just i don't know i just
put it out there and i
[Laughter]
i
happy birthday
this is 37. yes this yes are these no
they are no they're not yes they are oh
my bad bottoms right here no they're not
yes i can prove it they're bad buttons
they're bare bottoms right here these
are bad that's where they got bare
bottoms these are bare bottom shorts
these are
they really are so i wouldn't lie to you
these are bare bottom shorts right here
it's the clothing for go it's the go to
four guys looking to update their
wardrobe with high quality and made to
last threads without dishing out a small
fortune these are bare bottom styles you
just proved it the bare bottom is for
the the young youthful or older male on
the go that's very hip and cool like
myself and uh they have everything from
bathing suits to athleisure to
sweatshirts to things you could wear
anyway
look it sounds glassy yeah that you just
you just got bottomed
with over ten thousand five star reviews
you know they're not messing around
right now our listeners get free
shipping on their first order of these
super comfortable threads at
bearbottomclothing.com
with code hey babe just go to
bailbottomclothing.com that's b-e-a-r
like the animalbottomclothing.com
and use her babe to get free shipping on
your first order
barebottomclothing.com it's the best
clothes you can have and i i just heard
i was listening to an interview the
other day they said elliott page's new
go-to wardrobe is barebottomclothing.com
congratulations god bless
okay
listen
sal
i've been talking to you about your
psychosis
recently you know we've all been talking
to you about it about how your you know
your psychosis is is getting to a place
where not that we're uncomfortable no
what's funny is that we're like being
playful but you are actually hitting a
very serious deal yeah
i swear to god no i'll be crying myself
to sleep
south families
when these guys came on i actually did
take a look at it and i have been using
it and i have been recommending it and i
really think it's something that people
like better hub will assess your needs
and match you with a licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating under 48 hours there's a
broad range of experts available that
may not be otherwise locally available
yes in your area it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's just
professional counseling and it's done
securely it's done securely go to
betterhelp.com hey babe that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and joining over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional the special offer for hey
babe listeners get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com
hey babe so go check it out get your
mental health in check we're all nut
bags that's right um i feel everything
you just said everything you say right
now minus the children yes okay yeah i'm
not alone no i live my life in a in a
way where i'm just putting one foot in
front of me yeah just and i feel like
inside my head there's a storm yeah like
i think it's hard not to feel that way
coming out of a global pandemic but like
all the polarizing
[ __ ] that's going on and i know i think
i need to like really start to meditate
because like i go to my apartment right
now and i mean it is a mess like a
bomb hit it my clothes don't fit anymore
the clothes that do fit are literally
all over the place like my car a mess
like i'm a like a point of my life for
whatever reason like an absolute mess
things in the career are going well like
moving forward you know hopefully
continue but
i don't know what like a mess i think
like that thing where it's like in the
cartoons where like there's a leak
coming out of the side of the yeah like
that and another leak comes out and you
go like that and you go like that and
you're trying to plug
if everything's going smooth here
there's only so much capacity we have
mentally yeah and so much bandwidth we
have that if things are going good here
things are falling apart here it's
almost like juggling you know what i
mean here it is is a messy house a sign
of mental illness you might ask
psychology says that messiness can
indeed be a sign that a person is having
trouble just like someone who is
suffering from ocd and has to control
everything being a messy person might
show that they are dealing with
depression or some other mental illness
i would say ding ding
oh dude i have uh yeah i do that thing
sometimes where i can't get out of bed
but you have such a clean place i i know
i know i do keep everything very clean
but i'm also have ocd you show it in
other ways i'm obsessive compulsive
you know so every day you cannot get out
of bed yeah sometimes or i don't want to
it's hard to
right and i just feel like i don't want
to face anything like i just want to
stay under the goddamn cover soon you
feel
yeah of course it's stressful especially
you know gig to gig it's a lot it's a
lot so what do you do to combat it
um um take edibles yeah edibles
i have no idea marijuana helps also
being 29 helps a lot yeah that helps a
lot yeah yeah banking on that yeah i
think maybe i'm feeling it because
birthday 37 i'm starting to think i feel
the subconscious i feel like i look back
and i say okay where was i at 30 and i'm
certainly ahead in career-wise you know
37 you know got kids now god i have a
totally different life but sometimes i'm
like oh man you know i'll do something
very stupid where i'll be like
yeah but i'm not you know lebron james
is 37 too look at his life
you know yeah well it's tough to
complete yourself to lebron i wouldn't
do that right but i'm saying that's what
i'm saying
trevor noah is 37
okay he's a tough one to convey himself
to yeah very successful in his own right
space is saying stop comparing yourself
to black men
sure
or a successful look i would never
compare myself to like tom brady i can't
he's too successful well you would say
congratulations tim for just winning
this well i just won the
by the way patrick mahomes who's 15
years younger patriots 22 runner-up i'd
be remiss to not mention him nothing to
sneeze at nothing to sneeze at now i
have a question for you chris what was
your worst birthday you ever experienced
my worst birthday i've ever experienced
you know what something that this is
insane we're about to say but it's 100
true okay i do not remember
almost a single birthday i've ever had
in my life if you said what did you do
for your 21st birthday i have no clue
what's you for your 36th birthday i
genuinely have not a clue in the world
i'm trying to think if there is even a
birthday that i remember period and i'm
being honest with you right now
thinking about it i do not remember not
a single birthday of mine is that crazy
it's i don't think it's crazy actually
because i can only remember like a small
handful of mine right like specifically
where i was what i did why it was
special and i don't think i've even had
a celebration for my birthday like a
outward celebration in like since like
37 i remember because i got thrown a
surprise party at 37.
wow
is this my surprise party or surprise
come on out uh oh man if i could have i
would have what was the surprise what
happened oh it was amazing i walked into
like a like a venue i thought i was just
going to see like a like a band or
whatever and the whole place was rented
out for me wow and it was great it was
like a live music they i had a yacht
rock band oh my god playing like all 70
songs it was great it was catered it was
like chicken and wild it was fun it was
like it was my whole family all my
worlds collided there was like you know
a good probably almost maybe 100 people
or something like that there i don't
know that's crazy too because the 37th
birthday like it's pretty insignificant
like i feel pretty insignificant right
now
you remember yeah wow yeah the only one
that i okay the only
birthday i do remember and it speak and
this is just shows you like what a
lunatic i am i do remember
the day not necessarily what happened or
not there was a big party i probably
just had a carvel cake or whatever but i
do remember the day
of the my 33rd birthday because i
remember having pretty crippling anxiety
that that was the year i was going to
die because that's your jesus
which so i basically on on on a you know
in a parking lot outside of a target
compared myself to jesus christ yeah you
know which is ridiculous but we are made
in his image i was made into this that's
fine he said he's in all of us
you're made from him and by the way if
he's in all of us can't imagine all of
us gave consent so when is jesus's trial
when is jesus
i know he's in us all let's not mince
words
i would like to i would like to change
that up a little bit i know i mean let's
say you're in us all right it's i mean
by the way jesus i gave him full consent
to go he's in me jesus is gonna be
canceled soon enough
it's been thousands of years i can't
believe he's not telling me something's
not gonna come over from his past
something has to come up
something has to come up well yeah
there's times where i uh i'm so
overwhelmed that i don't know what to do
with myself
that moment
i could be in my home even
and there's just
the calls don't stop the emails don't
stop the texts don't stop the my to-do
list doesn't stop my brain doesn't stop
my insecurities don't stop my worries
don't stop
my stress my worry for my family doesn't
stop and i just get so overwhelmed that
i lit i don't know
what to do i've taken a knee before
not during not for the national anthem
nah not in that time
that whole thing too yeah i just i just
been like i can't even i literally take
a knee and i'm just like i i don't know
what to i feel so overwhelmed but i also
have um like you know crazy adhd and i
think that exacerbates all my feelings
story right same with everything we have
to start to meditate we have to start to
take 10 minutes in the morning and
meditate because i think if our bot and
stretch because i think if our bodies if
we felt better about our bodies
physically the mental would be like not
even a problem like like sometimes when
i say people who are ripped i mean
ripped in great shape i'm like how could
they honestly
have a mental issue when they just look
in the mirror and they're like dude
you're perfect right you know what i
mean
so that's what i think but i don't know
if that's true yeah that's that's a an
epidemic right now too though that's
happening
i mean i guess it happens to everybody
but but the influencers and like i mean
we sound like two old men now right but
like the k like like my nieces and stuff
i see them like you know
taking photos for instagram and doing
like these photo shoots and to like
putting on i'm like what are you guys
doing like you don't need to you don't
need to do that you know what i mean but
no i've never been happy with myself uh
physically in my life never in your life
once um maybe like
maybe like in high school have you just
accepted that or do you think about
daily i want to change it and i just
can't
um
yes yes yes yes
but i i just can't get it to the top of
the priorities i should because it is
health is like your number one health is
yeah yeah health is
what is health health is
important wealth health is wealth health
is wealth yeah that's what they say so
but i just can't i can't do it i don't
know what it is you do though you do you
get in hardcore that's what happens and
then you get you transform but they lose
it you you go back and forth but but see
i do too but i don't get i i fluctuated
probably okay on camera in the last 10
like 10 years on camera i probably
fluctuate up and down 40 pounds five
times wow really yeah yeah i just do
that over my life that's right you ever
see yourself on tv like you know i know
not that you watch it in a cup but but
when you see yourself 40 pounds ago does
that change your whole day where you're
like i don't mind it when i'm 40 pounds
lighter no no i hate it when i'm 40
heavier heavier yeah yes because what
happens with me is like if i if i some
like somebody posted something to me the
other day and i saw and i was like oh my
god dude i was literally 30 pound like
what happened and then when i did i saw
it i saw it
that happened i went right up the street
to a little cupcake shop and i got a
crumb cake yeah that's just one
cause it got wild right you really did
that you feel better you really did that
i should have went for a jog but going
for a jog sucks because it reminds me
hey you're an idiot you let yourself go
again you dummy when did you stop
because you were just in la like
six weeks ago something like that yeah
and you were weren't you still
exercising out there me and pimp are
going to barry's boot camp all the time
oh see you even do that we were doing
that what was that no i just lost it but
you but you stayed you're still in
you're still working out oh you know i
like working out but i don't like people
screaming at me to go faster than the
treasure no no what i'm saying when me
and you were in l.a together exercising
you when we got back to new york you
continued yeah i like it yeah yeah i'll
tell you how much has been on my mind
i'm thinking about getting a peloton get
it because i hear people talking about
it peloton if you're listening and we
know that you are
please send us a few pelotons why not
dude throw us a peloton give us a promo
code what are you crazy let's do let's
do a peloton commercial how about this
you ready for this try it out and i'll
be honest and give me a pelton ready for
this paluton you send us a peloton right
now a few of them yeah send us three
we'll do a hey babe on a peloton
we'll do hey babe we'll do an entire hey
babe episode oh my god
and we'll see we'll see who's put them
right next to each other and just go
forward and we'll do the show as is
somebody who knows somebody who works at
peloton can you come on this clip please
thank you i um and it's so funny because
you're saying peloton and because it's
peloton rhymes with cinnabon i want a
cinnamon cinnabon 12 very strange ways
of celebrating your birthday in
different parts of the world let's hear
them by the way happy birthday to
anybody else whose birthday is also
august 26th the ones i know off the top
of my head
macaulay culkin no [ __ ] yeah same age as
you no couple years older but people
used to say i look exactly like him when
i was a kid and it's strange that we
have the same birthday there it is
in china they don't eat cake but noodles
on their birthday which they celebrate
every 10 years and they also eat noodles
pretty much for most meals i was going
to say time out they eat noodles every
day also they only celebrate their
birthday every 10 years in china
is that possible
but extremely long new yeah i mean like
hey look if any of our chinese fans
i kind of like that whoa whoa whoa they
don't celebrate their birthdays every
year like we do but every 10 years i
like that
i like that man i like that a lot i'd
rather do it every ten years on the song
the bigger on the tens i remember them
dude right now i'm three and a half
i know i'd be three and a half why would
they do that though
what's it once a year is not that
frequent
it's celebrating everybody's all the
time every year though could you imagine
your 40th birthday you've in china
you've only celebrated four birthdays by
then
that's crazy i kind of like that you
know what you know what i'm happy about
everything five every five i'm no i'm
gonna make a decision right now
i will now only celebrate my birthdays
as if i'm living in china i want chinese
birthdays only that's what's going to
make it memorable don't think about
next august 26 you even tell you even
even don't even think about it i will
respond to you in fluent mandarin i'll
just hand you a fistful of noodles and
be silent that's what i want 40 i want
the surprise party wow 40th birthday one
surprise party gonna do a big 40. i i
would like you to be in charge of it and
i want a chinese 40.
oh my god i want a chinese fortunately
all right all right all right
cause you always remember stuff like
that i will i'm saying it today chinese
40th
you're in charge i'm gonna do it you're
a joke chris has already requested you
booked 1975 for his 40th previously
chinese 40th 1975.
yeah oh my god all right i'll wait a
little while because maybe in a couple
years they might fall on hard times and
be more uh
right now they're top of the world they
just sold out the garden well did they
they do so in two years i should be able
to afford them for your party 100 yeah
yeah yeah it'll get it should get worse
by then
in canada you spread butter on your nose
again i did that this morning
a second to call out how different china
it's like just a bunch of moose or
something yeah
yeah they're just like you celebrate
every 10 years hey oh we've butter on
our nose
that's so funny well to be honest with
you it if you combine if you were a
canadian
chinese couple
what you would do is and you had the
same birthday you would say i put the
butter on my nose you got the noodle dip
the noodle on my nose everybody wins
every 10 years if i was the the asian
person in the relationship of an asian
canadian person or the chinese person in
the relationship with chinese canadian
i'd be like
you know what tomorrow is it's my 40th
birthday for the last 10 years i've been
smearing butter on your nose
yeah every year you better go
gangbusters
i love the canadian guy too who
remembers it's his birthday and it's
like [ __ ] i gotta go to the store and
get land likes
it's my birthday or like the mom's like
we don't have any landlakes honey we
can't celebrate your
in vietnam everyone celebrates their
birthday at the same time individual
birthdays are rare they're often
celebrate the same time as the
vietnamese new year i like that we're in
it together whoa what
i like that we're in it together so new
year's they're new there's a night where
everyone's like no your birthday could
be today it could be literally seven
months from now we're all celebrating
now yeah i'll tell you what
lit doesn't it make it less special it
makes it less special but more communal
and i do not know in vietnam how the
carvels keep up with those orders on
that day
what do they do you literally just have
to work one day you can't keep fudgy the
whale on the show go away
in brazil you pull people by the ears
okay funny dish pulling on the earlobe i
guess that's why they're all like that's
the worst one so far brazil brazil just
took a hot turd in the united kingdom
and ireland they bounce people up and
down in the air like children
i mean that's kind of i mean if you can
lift my 245 pound fat ass i i've never
seen that happening yeah i've yeah i've
never heard of any of these actually in
south africa when you celebrate your
21st birthday you received the key as a
gift south african parents gave the key
to their children when they turned 21
which is a symbol for responsibility and
the future that is opening up before
them okay at 21 i'd lose the key yeah i
would imagine 90 of those kids do not
have to keep by their 22nd birthday yeah
they fully lost it imagine not giving a
kid the key on his 21st to make a
statement as a parent you say you're not
you ain't ready
you ain't ready
in nepal colored yogurt which they've
spelled colored
c-o-l-o-u-r-e-d and yogurt
y-o-g-h-u-r-t is applied to the forehead
[Laughter]
i mean sure okay yeah colored yogurt is
applied to the floor what is that where
is it why why why because and yeah i
don't know underneath there or maybe you
scroll yeah like what is in nepal
colored yogurt is applied to the
forehead are literally good enough to
eat on the day
of their birthdays
it's colored yogurt there's people doing
it they put it right in their forehead
maybe it's good for the skin in ghana
the birthday cake consists of eggs and
onions so i don't know if that's a cake
more of it is a frittata yeah why aren't
we just calling it what it is it's eggs
and onions you're having an omelet in
germany on your 16th birthday you have
to eat [ __ ]
in germany it says you have flour thrown
on your head
for your 18th it's an egg
so you sweet 16 you get flour on your
head the 18th it's an egg
on minokoy island when babies reach 20
days old the parents shave the baby's
hair and sell it well i got news for you
my
my 20 day old baby it's bald
where is minokoy island and who's taking
blades to an infant's skull i'm not
gonna look i want to guess i've never
heard of minokoi island pull up
geography where many coin island is i'm
not looking i'm gonna guess minokoy
island is off the coast
of
i'm not looking south okay minokoi
island is it off the coast of something
am i right on that or or doesn't it it's
an island in in
off of a is it its own country
or is it uh it's i i would be giving it
away if i uh
okay okay minokoi island it's part of
the philippines
no
no minokoi island
minokoi island is it is it right to say
that it's actually i'll tell you
no
yeah
yeah
okay it's off to
sri lanka
it's close
close sudan
it's it's close it's it's indonesia it's
it's it's it's it's it's it's it's off
of india right across from sri lanka wow
okay so it technically it is off the
coast of sri lanka it is but it's off
the co all right listen second life hey
babe minnekoy island get your tickets
never what do they do there seoul joel's
got a place on minnekoy island so
there's just bald babies
there's a people are just purchasing
children's
hair god knows the fine hair is our
weight and the equivalent of this weight
in silver is donated to a charitable
organization okay so they're going
different to charity okay
in china for a baby's first birthday
which i hey now now i'm getting confused
because i thought they only did every
10. i know in china for a baby's first
birthday they put objects in front of
them to determine their future and
there's
this is the sunny water there's a white
child holding it
so
that's which is tap water that's
purified in pennsylvania yes
so i don't know what that baby is very
chinese of them
yeah the white baby holding at the sami
all right all right well i um it's
interesting it's searching the birthday
traditions i uh yeah so i you know i
didn't even eat cake for you
i'm getting you had you had cake this
morning i had cake decisions no that was
the other day right you did have crumb
cake today i have crumb cake the other
day today i'm going to pizzeria uno
tonight that's what i do oh that's a
nice deep dish yeah that's just nice you
were there not that long ago because you
texted me from that yeah i go there a
lot two years ago they raised over there
ninety-seven bay ridge on 92nd and
fourth three years ago i went to uh when
me and uh my girl were not together we
were co-parenting she gave me i got to
lila our daughter for new year's eve and
we dressed up in a suit and i put her in
a little dress for new year's eve and
went to pizzeria uno really and that was
actually one of the only new year's eves
that i really remember i only remember
two or three new year's eve one i
remember because i was it was really
tough going through a bad breakup the
second one
the me and delilah's um
pizza once and the third one i was on
stage at gotham comedy club on stage
somebody threw i was like the headlining
act for new year's eve and somebody
threw a full knot cup a full bottle of
champagne at me and what happened they
got thrown out wow
they were joking or they had they took
offense or something you said or i think
it was a mix of both i think they were
think i was having a great set which in
fairness i wasn't and they were all so
drunk
literally i remember angelo lozado r.i.p
was the host and he did such a
phenomenal job of coming he literally
saw that and rather than losing the
crowd just came up onto stage and calmed
them all down and we did the countdown
and everything was fine but literally
the set was going like pretty well at
about 11 50 because i had to go on stage
11 55 and then we would do like five
minutes wrap-up countdown whatever at 11
50 i lost them 100 percent gone like a
like i was performing for a full
cafeteria right in the middle of a food
fight right right gone wow like that
like
what was it like 11 49 things are fine
11 50. gone and i just was like you know
like i don't know again i was like you
know guys like we still have you know
it's counting down
and people are yelling stuff like it's
been new year's eve it's been new year's
day in australia for 12 hours already
just yelling things that don't matter
you know it's new year's eve in halifax
it was like
new year's day so so um that's the only
other new year's i don't like new year's
no
the celebration of new year's not really
as as a guy when i was younger apart it
was a good party but i'm over that and i
also it also makes me reflect and get
depressed yes i i don't want more time
to pass
oh my god and i um i can't dude their
new year's i [ __ ] forgot the new year's
eve that
the the one we're forgetting me and you
we didn't use we didn't even remember
the one not the one man the craziest
thing happened
yes this is with a babe that's right
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say
[Music]
this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ]